İyi geceler Sizi birazcık Kendinizden
kurtarmaya geldim
bu Fakat tabii ki 15 dakikalık kısa bir
konuşma olacağı için bu konuşmayı
bu elinizden geldiğince yatağınıza
götürmeniz iri kendi işinizde devam
ettirmenizi isteyeceğim yaparsanız çok
mutlu olursunuz Umarım rüyalarınıza
gider bu konuşma ve içerlerde birşeyleri
çalıştırır Bu ne demek kendinden
kurtulmak İnsanın kendisi hedefleri olan
Arzuları olan amaçları olan bir canlı
Ama tabii ki bunlar da bize bir takım
Güçler kazandırıyor bazı taraflarımız
güçlü oluyor ve bu güçlerin bizi ne
kadar dar attığını Anlatmaya çalışacağım
size
bu gücünüzün ne kadar aynı zamanda
güçsüzlük olabileceğini Anlatmaya
çalışacağım Çünkü yolculuk en çok bunun
için lazım Çünkü insan bir yolculuk
yaptığında
bu hem kendimden gider hem de kendine
doğru gider her Eğer çok hesaplanmamış
sa Eğer çok planlı değil SP Eğer
karşılaşmalara Hayret Edoş kuyuya
etkilenmeye bunun sürtmesine düşmeye
başaramama ya kendini bırakırsa
kendinden gider ve kendine gider Ben Tıp
Fakültesi mezunuyum çok erken bir yaşta
son derece gezip B son derece kendinden
emin ukala bir genç doktor kent
Evet Ee o bekleme odalarında bekleme
salonlarında bekleyen hasta ve hasta
yakınlarıyla karşılaşırken o kadar hızlı
yürürdüm ki önlerinden de o kadar da
dimdik o kadar da kendinden emin stres
topu da bir alet gibi kullanmanın
dışında Ben doktorum diye de boynuma
astığım hatırlıyorum bunu bir halt
zannediyordum Çünkü o aslında benim
sadece Şifa ya giden yolda kullanmam
gereken bir alete Ötesi değildi Oysa ki
ve birden bire bir hastaya kat dağın
açarken kattan böyle Küçük bir cerrahi
müdahale gibi görünen bir şey eğilmiştim
uzun bir süre Tokat daldı uğraştıktan
sonra böyle kaldım arkadaşlar
Sen de benim de çok ciddi bir mesele
oluşmuştu ve bir ciddi bir kuvvet Kaybım
vardı Acilen beni bir takım tetkikler
falan yapıldı ve beni aldılar Baran
ameliyathaneye götüreceğim acilen
ameliyata gireceğim O züppe var ya
dimdik yürüyen bir yeşil giydirdiler
bana önden düğmesi yok arkadan düğmesi
var kıçında çok güzel açık Bu çok iyi
ondan sonra beni sev diye aldılar
götürmeye başladılar götürmeye
başladıklarında Şunu fark ettim ki ben
hastaneyi duvarlar zannediyor muşum
Çünkü ben hep dik yürüdüğüm içine
pastanenin duvarlarını izliyormuş ben o
zaman fark ettim ki hastane Aslında
tavanlar dır çünkü hastane Aslında yatan
insanların gezdiği dolaştı durduğu
yaptığı bir yer tavanlar çok çirkindi
ben eğer kıçım açılma saydı
bu duvarlardan tavanlara dönemeyecek
Team Bu benim için başlangıçta iyi bir
yolculuktu buna benzer çok deneyim
yaşadım hayatın birçok alanında
yolculukları mı da buna göre planladım
bir tane daha örnek vereyim Bir tane kız
arkadaşım var yıllar önce çok başarılı
çok iyi bir eğitim almış En bireyler
şunlar bunlar çok son derece tatlı Zeki
özel bir kız ve bu Team Leader olacak ve
çok önemli bir şirkette Dönemin en
önemli şirketinde hala da çok önemli bir
şirketin Genel Müdürlüğünde Team Leader
olacağım diyor Ben de altı aydır onun
Team Leader olması ve ilgili rekabet
süreçlerini vesairenin dinliyorum sonra
bir gün beni aradı dedi ki tatlım ben
Team Leader oldum dedi Ah bir tanem Ben
seni yemeğe götüreceğim Kutlayacak
kutlayalım bunu dedi Bi gittik yemeğe
gittik ve onu kutladım falan filan ve
sordum Ona Senin tim'de kaç kişi var
dedim
13 dedim
Allah kahretsin 3 dedi ama o binanın
içindeki meselelerin değerlikleri öyle
şişer ki öyle önemli bir halde
zannederiz ki olabiliriz hayatımızı ona
doğru yürütürüz
tek bir soru soracağım kendinize
sormanız için ben şu yum diye bir
tarihte bulunmaya çalışın içinizden Eğer
Bunların içinde ben başarılıyım Ben
doktorum Ben yazarım ben iş adamıyım Ben
Türk'üm ben şu yum buyum diye bir şeyle
bitiriyor sanız o şey sizin Kendinizden
aynı zamanda uzaklaştığını anlamına
gelir
de o şey sizi o şeyi içine tıkar
da mutlaka mutlaka bunun dışına çıkacak
ve konforunuzu bozacak deneyimlere doğru
yürümektir yolculuk Onun için sadece
yolculuklarda yaşadığımız değil bir
başka kişiyle kurduğumuz ilişkide de biz
Aslında bir anlamda yolculuk yaparız ve
zorlanırız anne olursun çocuğun öğretir
kırar burnunu
bu hekimsen iyi bakarsan kırar burnunu
ne yaparsan yap kurduğun ilişkilerinizi
Aşk çok Tekamül ettirilir Niye
zorlanırız bir yandan da çekip gidem
emektir bir yandan da kayıt duygusuyla
çalışmaktadır gidemezsin Tekamül edersin
bütün bu yolculuk meselesinin en temel
meselesi en temel amacı bu şaşırmaya bu
burun sürtmesine bu dağılmaya kendini
tekrar tarif etmeye ve ben şundan Ben
benim Ee geçecek bir yol olması Dere
yolculuk kıymetlidir yoksa bir takım tur
şirketlerinin hazırladığı tur
programlarıyla gittiğiniz ve şimdi bu
bize girdik Ondan sonra önümüzde bayrak
taşıyan bir kadının arkasından sonra da
şunu gezdik dediğiyle şeye yolculuk
zannediyorsanız O bir yolculuk değil
ve bu gezi belki bilmiyorum ama yolculuk
bir diğerini uzanmak bir yerlerde
kendinde karşılaşmak ve karşılaştığın
kendini sorgulamak anlamına gelir
O rilke'nin çok sevdiğim bileti var
benim böyle Twitter ya Instagram
hesabımda şöyle bir şey yazar Hatta
böyle bir sergi açtım sandığınız değilim
sandığınız şeylerden hiç biri değilim
sandıkta değilim diye şu çünkü bütün bu
ay diyetlerin beni nasıl dar attığını
biliyorum yazar olmak demek yazar duruşu
demek olduğu an bittin sen
Op.Dr olmak demek Doktor duruşu
dediğinde bittin sen bunların hepsi
azaltıcı İlke şöyle diyor
bu Şöhret diyor türkçesinde Master
rapitasyon dan bahsediyor Herkesin kendi
içinde bir şöhreti vardır aile içinde
bir rapitasyon muz vardır toplumun
içinde kasabada yaşıyorsanız kasabada
sizi bir şekilde belirler bir şekilde
tarif edilmiş siniz dir öyle duyun bu
işareti Şöhret diyor kişinin benlik
arazisinin başkaları tarafından işgali
dir diyor kendinizi tanımladığınız OHAL
sizin aynı zamanda işgalin izdir sadece
kadın gibi tarif ediyorsunuz o
ediyorsanız kendinizi işgal edildiniz
Sadece anne diye tarif ettiyseniz gene
işgal edildi demektir ve hatta bir yerde
diyor ki eğer bir gün herkesin bildiği
bir isminiz olursa
Allah herkesin bildiği bir isminiz
olursa benim tüylerimi diken diken eder
bu bir gece yarısı elinizi havaya
kaldırın ve Tanrıdan hiç kimsenin
bilmediği yepyeni bir isim isteyince
ya ben bu yolculuk meselesini
bu giderayak Belki sizi birazcık da
güldürecek ama bir de şöyle denedim bir
aralar şöyle seyahatlere çıkmaya
başladım dedim ki arabayla çıkacağım
belediye çıkacağımı gideceğimi
bilmeyeceğim
bu nereye satacağını da bilmeyeceğim
Yolumun nereye gideceğini hiç
girmeyeceğim hiç bir anlatmayacağım
Arkadaşlar ben yaklaşık ilk 12 saat çok
ağır bir şey yaşadım şu Çünkü bana
Beynimin burasından bir ses sürekli şunu
soruyorum nereye gidiyoruz Ben de bunu
hazırlamıştım Ya bilmiyorum nereye
gidiyorsun bilmiyorum nereye gidiyorsun
bilmiyorum ve şunu fark ettim ki ben çok
bilindik hesaplarla hep hesaplarla
spontane TL kendini bırak ama dana kamu
yan bir adam olmuşum Demek ki dedim
akmayı unutmuşum
Daha sonra bir şekilde ben bu akmayı
başardım
ve Bir Sabah 4.00 gibi iki şehrin
arasında bir pavyon gördüm mesela
o yeşil plana saldırı vardı kapıda banda
kasa Mercedesler falan vardı Ben Benim
arabam hiç Onlarınki de benzemiyordu ama
ben orada durdum içeri girdim ve ben
onlardan onlar da benden çok
korkuyorlardı Çünkü ben onlara
benzemiyorum Onlar da bana benzemiyor
lardı
bu ve bu korku üzerinde düşündüm onların
Korkular üzerine düşündüm de
ve en komiği ama şuydu Belki yüzünüzde
bir tebessüm ile Benden ayrılırsınız bu
adam kararttı içimizi demezsiniz birden
bire bir radara yakalandım ve radara
yakalandım da bana ceza keserler polis
memuru arabamız zorunlu trafik sigortası
olmadığını da söyledi Eyvah Normalde
arabayı bağlamamız lazım beyefendi ama
dedi bize söz verin ileride Ilgın diye
bir kasaba var oradan yaptırın dedi Ben
de demek ki Ilgın'a gitmem lazımmış diye
Ilgın'a daldım Ilgın içine girdim bir
köprü Nehir ve olması lazım Böyle büyük
bir zehir bekliyorum Bu kadar yüksek
debili değil neresi falan derken
göremedim de arabayı da köprü tenha
kenara çektim bir baktım bir mezarlık
fakat mezarlık böyle taşlardan oluşuyor
hiç başka bir şey yok isim falan yok ben
oraya dedim ki burası sticks olsa gerek
önderima paçalarımı sıyırdım biraz Six
Irmağı'nda yürümek istedim yürüdüm
bu sonra çocukluğunda oynadığım bir oyun
geldi aklıma o oyun şuydu Erzurum daydım
Erzurum'da çok güzel Selçuklu camileri
vardır camilerden birinin minaresinde
kafayı takardım ona ulaşmaya çalışırdım
yol bir sağ giderdi bir sola giderdi
uzaklaştırdım yaklaşırdı buna ne kadar
oraya giderdim bir türbe gördüm gördüm
Kümbet gibi onu aynı oyunu oynamak
istedim ve arabayla gene çok zor buldum
yaklaştım en sonunda bir kadına sordum
bir teyzeye sordum Teyze de ki benim
evim bahçesi dedi ben girebilir miyim
türbeye dedim Tabii ki girersin dedi ama
dedi çakmağın veya kibritin var mı dedi
var dedim içeri girdim çakma yaktım ben
bu şekli çizilmiş vardır Ben de başı
böyle Duran ayakları Bilmem duran bir
ceset Arkadaşlar bu
bu üzerine bir battaniye silinmiş bir
sandık adam bahsetmiyorum bile sandukada
olur ya değil bir ceset yatıyor üzerinde
de battaniye var o
bu korkuyla merakın yan yana olduğu
güzel an vardır ya çok acayip tir Ben de
o korkuyla merak arasında dolaştıktan
sonra üç İhlas bir Fatiha okudum ondan
sonra eğildim ve getirdiği görmek üzere
battaniyeye şöyle hafifçe kaldırdım bir
baktım ki teyze turşuları kurmuş
küplerin en büyüğü burada biraz daha
küçükler burada ayak kısmında da
birazcık daha büyükçe bir şey var ben
hayatınızda turşuya Fatih Okumuş ilk
insanı
o turşu Baba Türbesi derim ben oraya bu
tür karşılaşmalar zamanımızın olsaydı
size daha ağır daha derinlikli daha
acıtıcı anıları anlatmak isterdim ama bu
tür karşılaşmalar bu tür hayretler bu
tür duygular başka düşmekte böyle bir
şeydir iyi ilişkide böyle bir şeydir
anne baba olmak da böyle bir şeydir Eğer
saat Kolunuzu sürekli ağırlıkla
çalıştırırsanız çok güçlü bir sağ
kolunuz olur ve hayatınızı o Sağ kola
yürütür siniz hiç de eksik
hissetmezsiniz
var ama ne olur sol kolunuza mecbur
kaldığınız yerlere gidin
o lütfen sol kolunuza mecbur kaldığınız
yerde yolculuklara çıkın
ve emekçilerin ve kendinizde
zehirlenmenin İnsanın kendisi ve kendini
tarifi kendini de zehirlemek Theory
yolculuk birazcık da dediğim gibi
kendimizden birazcık da kendimize
gittiğimiz yerin adıdır çok teşekkür
ediyorum
[Alkış]